ein wahlergebnis das kann man nicht
uminterpretieren oder guten wünschen die
das ist zunächst mal so dass wir uns
präsentieren das ist dagegen runter in
die demokratie man muss auch jeder
selber dann seine verantwortung
definieren wir dabei an
und auch schauen jemand daraus positive
energien sinken meine aufgabe ist also
das ist das mandat hier waren zunehmend
für die csu dann auch wenn sie und ihr
ins gespräch werden die alexander doppel
zusammen
weil sie eine welche und überhaupt sei
das sicherlich wenn es uns gelungen gibt
nicht 20 17 wiederum endlose gespräche
und pausen auf den balkonen das glaube
ich es nicht etwas was die leute
begeistern oder waren sie schneller
bezügliche entscheidungen gerade bei den
konstellationen zum knappen und ins tor
gehen unsere video partner beteiligt
sind meine aufgabe ist dass parteichef
sozial ist anders
spekulation
kein nährboden hand und raps gewesen
alles ich kenne zunächst nur eines sagen
die wissenschaftler
die besten chancen kanzler zu werden hat
derzeit olaf scholz was wird heute
nachmittag in dieser fraktionssitzung
passieren sie sind hier bei allen
entwicklungen live dabei denn paul
ronzheimer ist mit uns im studio der
über sein handy alles erfahren wird
nirgendwo meine damen und herren im
deutschen fernsehen erfahren sie in
echtzeit was hinter geschlossenen türen
passiert nur hier bei uns paul herzlich
willkommen und annika rage ist bei uns
sie hat armin laschet über sieben wochen
lang im wahlkampf verfolgt kein anderer
reporter in deutschland war so lange so
nah dran an armin laschet und sie wird
uns einschätzen können wie am ende
stellt sich fühlen muss jetzt in dieser
situation paul was wird heute nachmittag
in dieser fraktionssitzung passieren es
ist eine der spannendsten tage die es in
der geschichte der union gegeben hat es
steht alles auf der kippe zum einen
natürlich das kanzleramt wir haben
gehört was markus söder gesagt hat er
ist damit armin laschet in den rücken
gefallen viel heftiger hätte man das
nicht machen können auf der einen seite
den herzlichen glückwunsch endlich sagt
es mal einer auf der anderen seite für
armin laschet natürlich bitter dass der
rivale markus söder der natürlich eine
rechnung offen hat jetzt mit so klaren
worten das sagt was ihr auch wir hier
bei bild immer gesagt haben olaf scholz
ist der wahlgewinner und momentan
niemand anders das ist das eine das
andere ist es geht heute darum wer wird
fraktionschef warum er so wichtig wer
fraktionschef wird das ist der
mächtigste posten den man haben kann
neben dem parteichef und dieser
fraktionschef der gewählte würde in
einer oppositionsrolle also wenn die
union es nicht schaffen sollte jamaika
zustande zu bringen und in die regierung
zu kommen der wichtigste job sein in der
fraktion dem modell wir sehen dass hier
gerade nochmal eigentlich brinkhaus
haben wer jetzt der fraktionsvorsitzende
ist wer wollte will auch antreten noch
mal um weiter für ein weiteres jahr so
tun muss mäßig gewählt zu werden heute
armin laschet wollte das verhindern er
wollte dass er nur kommissarisch diese
rolle weiter führt bis dann geklärt ist
welche verhandlungen es geben wird um
dann möglicherweise selber
fraktionsvorsitzender werden zu können
sei es als oppositionsführer armin
laschet hat gestern nacht versucht in
einer aktion erst hier gelandet in
berlin mitten in der nacht gegen 11 uhr
30 also kurz vor mitternacht und dann
hat er sich noch getroffen mit ralph
brinkhaus und darüber zu sprechen ob man
ihn davon abbringen kann seinen ersten
handy alarm paul das war in dem fall ein
anruf nicht weggedrückt hat aber
tatsächlich gibt es
informationen die wir haben und zwar ist
folgendes passiert in den
vorbesprechungen
haben wir erfahren dass armin laschet
einen vorschlag unterbreiten will er
will einen vorschlag unterbreiten das
bis bereit brinkhaus bis april gewählt
werden soll ralph brinkhaus als
fraktionschef bis april
das ist das was armin laschet offenbar
vorschlagen will das ist das was wir aus
den vorgesprächen vor dieser
fraktionssitzung die um 17 uhr beginnt
bereits hören das soll der vorschlag von
armin laschet sei wichtig zu sagen es
gibt stand jetzt keinen geeigneten
vorschlag zwischen markus söder und
armin laschet auch das ein zeichen dass
da eine offene schlacht droht in der
fraktion den alexander dobrindt markus
söder statthalter hier sozusagen der
landesgruppenchef er hat schon gesagt
dass das was armin laschet vor hat also
vorübergehend dass das keinen sinn mache
und dass man eigentlich ein jahr einen
fraktionschef mindestens wählen sollte
also wir können uns auf heftige
diskussionen einstellen gleichzeitig
gibt es offenbar auch einen vorschlag
die wahl des fraktionschefs komplett zu
bannen also dass diese wahl doch nicht
stattfinden soll auch die sind vorschlag
gibt es aber noch einmal was wir jetzt
hören armin laschet will vorschlagen
dass ralph brinkhaus der bisherige
fraktionschef bis april gewählt wird das
erfahren wir hier exklusiv gerade aus
den vorgesprächen die gerade statt